if a person by profession deals
inba or as it's been now translated
interest does this mean that uh their
fast would not be
accepted as far as R is concerned RBA is
a major sin
it's and R has been mention the Quran in
no less than any different places Allah
mentions it in Surah Al Imran chapter 3
verse number 130 Ina chapter number 4
verse number 161 it's mentioned Thrice
in Surah Bak CH 2 vers number 275 it's
also mentioned in Surah Bak CH 2 vers
276 and also in Surah bakar CH 2 vers
number 278 and 279 and I quote that last
verse only I don't intend giving a
speech Allah says in Surah bakar CH 2
vers number 278 and 279 that give up
what remains of a demands of Usery and
anyone who does not give up the demands
of Usery interest is Arabic word if
anyone does not give up the demand of
Interest then take notice of a war from
Allah and his rol if anyone deals in Rah
in interest in user Allah and his will
wage a war against you it's more serious
it's a bigger sin than having alcohol
it's a bigger sin than taking drugs
because when you have alcohol when you
take drugs when you have poke it's a big
sin but Allah and his will not w a or
against you but if you involve yourself
in take or give both when you take
interest or give interest both of them
are major sins so if a person is
involving in
RBA it will not break the fast per
because I've told you things that break
the fast I've already mentioned total 10
things so this does not come in that but
it's a major sin a person should abstain
throughout his life especially in the
month of Ramadan which is the month of
forgiveness month of blessing it will
only reduce his reward what reward he
get for fasting his fasting will not be
nullified it will not be invalidated but
the reward will be reduced and as a
beloved Prophet mallam said say inkari
number three in the book of fasting
Hadith number 19 1903 a beloved Prophet
said a person does not
leave his false actions and false talks
Allah does not require him to leave his
drink and eating the person who does not
abstain from doing wrong things saying
wrong things Haram things Allah does not
require him to leave his eating and
drinking so based on this it is Haram
his reward for the month of fasting will
be reduced it may be nullified also